in 1991 while investigating the concept
of creating a much darker version of
venom david michelinie looked at killing
off the main alter ego of venom eddie
brock and having the Venom symbiote
transfer from one host to another
eventually setting on a character who
would be a total psychopath Marvel
rejected the idea under the guise that
venom and Eddie Brock had become one of
the most popular duo's in the history of
Marvel Comics and there would be a
severe backlash at the hands of Marvel
Comics fans if they were eliminated
david michelinie went back to the
drawing board and after several
revisions came up with one of the most
popular super villains of all time and
the spider-man universe what's going on
guys
this is Rob and today we're going to be
talking about carnage so as the story
with carnage unfolds we learn that what
happens is after the defeat of Eddie
Brock Eddie Brock is left in Alcatraz
serving a sentence and the Venom
symbiote is kind of trying to seek out
different people seek out different
hosts and ultimately manages to locate
Eddie Brock it bonds with Eddie Brock
and Alcatraz and leaves behind an
offspring that merges with Eddie Brock
cellmate Cletus Kasady now Cletus Kasady
was a complete and total psychopath
devoid of virtually any moral code
whatsoever and it's really kind of
interesting here because Cletus Kasady
despite the fact that he is a normal
human being just doesn't view the world
the same way that we do he views the
world of order and structure as an
illusion and views chaos and murder and
mayhem as the true nature of the world
now what's really kind of cool here is
that he's not entirely wrong I mean say
for example that we read someone like
Thomas Hobbes Thomas Hobbes was an 18th
19th century British philosopher who
held a viewpoint that society in a state
of nature that is to say society without
an ordered government would be engaged
in a perpetual and permanent war of all
against all based on resources because
resources are not infinite and someone
somewhere would be perceived as having
more than someone else and so there
would always be some kind of term
and that things like structure and order
and governments would rise up not
because humanity wants it to be that way
but because it has to be that way to
keep humanity from destroying itself now
the difference between carnage and venom
here is that of course carnage is the
offspring the the kind of symbian
offspring so to speak of venom and
because of the fact that the offspring
just stated in the environment of the
planet Earth it now has a whole new set
of powers in addition to the abilities
that venom has and spider-man hath
because always always keep in mind that
because the Venom symbiote first bonded
with spider-man
anyone who bonds with the Venom symbiote
or any offspring that the Venom symbiote
is going to have will have the base
powers of spider-man in addition to
whatever powers it develops after that
now with cletus kasady
he is kind of the result of a troubled
childhood cletus kasady of course i
think it killed his grandma when he was
at the age of 8 he was put into a foster
home he killed some kids who were
picking on him and then burned down the
foster home he's always been kind of
mentally unstable and mentally insane
the symbiote the carnage symbiote
actually merges with Cleese Cassidy's
blood stream with the Venom symbiote
merging with Eddie Brock and Flash
Thompson and other people it merged on a
surface level that is to say it simply
just kind of increased itself onto their
physical body and granted them different
abilities but it wasn't part of their
genetic makeup with carnage and cletus
kasady it wasn't that way with carnage
and cletus kasady because of the fact
that the carnage symbiote is part of his
bloodstream it will forever exist it
cannot be eradicated permanently the
only way to truly destroy it would be to
throw someone like Cletus Kasady into
the Sun that really be the only way to
destroy Cletus Kasady down to the most
finite atomic level of his body down to
the to the very last red blood cell and
actually there have been instances where
Cletus Kasady has more or less kind of
in stripped of the carnage symbiote but
he has in turn just kind of cut himself
and bled and the carnage symbiote tree
emerges now when I say that the carnage
symbiote is devoid of all morality I'm
saying this relative to venom venom of
course is a bad guy I mean we know that
venom is a bad guy he's one of the most
popular bad guys but despite this Eddie
Brock still has some measure of morality
he won't arbitrarily kill people for the
sole purpose of baiting spider-man to
come out and to engage him he'll simply
go and try to find spider-man with
carnage is not that way
carnage will just engage in acts of
murder just for the sheer fun of it
because to him is just enjoyable and one
of the more common practices is for him
to kill someone and then to write the
word carnage rules on the walls because
of this because of carnage is just
reckless disregard for any real sinless
of morality or humanity he was wildly
popular among the comic book base
because we had never really seen that in
a character in Marvel Comics we had
never really seen someone who was just
so devoid of morality that nothing
really mattered to them there was no
limit to how extreme of lengths they
would go to in order to bait a super
hero out into the open and he actually
spawned this great big huge 14 part
crossover series involving every single
super villain in the spider-man universe
and it ultimately culminated in
spider-man and venom coming together to
successfully stave off carnage and to to
do the best they could to remove carnage
the carnage symbiote from Cletus Kasady
but as we've said it couldn't be done at
a hundred percent now with regards to
the powers that carnage has again he has
the base powers of super I'm sorry of
spider-man he has the powers to climb
across walls he has some measure of
spider sense just because of the fact
that the the symbiote can see in
virtually all directions but he is
immune to both Venom's ability to track
his location and spider-man's
spider-sense and so he's a very
formidable opponent in addition to this
he can also kind of shoot these webbing
kind of projectiles from any part of his
body he can turn his arms and different
parts of his bodies into an any part of
his body into knives and stabbing
weapons he can put plant thoughts you
know kind of put people under a state of
mind control by injecting these tendrils
and into their brains he sort of use a
really powerful guy you know relatively
speaking to other characters and in fact
there was a point in the Marvel comics
when the carnage symbiote took over
Silver Surfer if you guys could imagine
that but ultimately there was a there
was one demonstration of a super serious
superhero having such extreme powers the
carnage stood no chance and of course
that was a century when the century
torment half
but nonetheless carnage is a very
formidable opponent he's a very
interesting opponent he's a very
intriguing opponent because of the fact
that for the most part when we look at
super villains in the Marvel Universe
they still exist by some kind of moral
code albeit a moral code that may exist
for their own selfish gains electro for
example was a supervillain who is really
kind of obsessed with destroying
spider-man and gaining money Magneto of
course was obsessed with the idea of
having mutants at the hierarchy of
society these were characters who had
some measure of morality and would
engage in their own kind of selfish
plans but wouldn't really disregard the
lives of other people
this is why one of the reasons why
carnage was so extreme so so yeah he's a
pretty formidable guy and there's a
reason why he's ranked number 90 among a
gns top 100 comic book villains of all
time because he's just so extreme so
with that being said I'm gonna go ahead
and read this video to an end hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace